I watched the election with Sharon Stone  at Sharon Stone's house of course we're  both Hillary fans and when it started to  go horribly wrong  she would say dance break in both of us  took our tops off go ahead and we were  just shaking our - are you serious my  hand to God and she looks great she  looks incredible and there were like 20  people there and are you kidding I'm I  swear to God both of us absolutely not  just bras bras off and dancing around  being silly I actually went over my  pajamas but you don't rub each other's  breasts through you that doesn't get  like he didn't become a lesbian show no  I think the Hillary disappointment was  so tangible that we couldn't even do any  faux lesbian hahaha you know what's odd  Hillary Clinton spent election night the  same way she was with her girlfriends  she take Papa took the time shimmy how  far come since you met me with two noses  ago and now I'm dancing naked at Sharon  Stone's house